I was an idiot um I was in love with a a
man that convinced me to co-sign on a
2019 Jetta in the fall of 2021 I'm not
in that relationship anymore but anyway
uh last summer I convinced him to turn
the vehicle back into to the dealer
basically voluntarily repossess it he
could not pay the payment on time and I
was also helping him and he made more
than me how much money how much money do
you have well I'm on baby step one I I'm
just starting now you don't have any
money I don't have any money I have
$33,000 in credit card debt that I have
uh Consumer Credit what do you make
61,000 a year okay what was owed on the
Jetta do you know 29,000 and change okay
let's say there's a
$115,000 deficit when you're done and
they come to you as the co-signer and
they want
$115,000 well the first thing you tell
them is what you told me I have no money